bonjour je vous vois déjà frémir mon
dieu des transparents des pauvres points
oui je suis ingénieur c'est les
ingénieurs sont nés transparence est
perdus c'est dramatique j'étais même pas
ingénieur jeter bat emma titien ça c'est
encore pire parce que j'aimais les maths
les maths mais mai et il n'y avait pas
de place pour le reste y compris pour
les filles un jour quelqu'un m'avait dit
les filles faut que tu les dracs j'ai
dit comment il faut les faire rire donc
j'arrive et vient sur mon sindou pour
épancher sa vidange ça marchait pas du
tout mais oui c'est dramatique crise ça
parle au cerveau cela va laisser
j'ai néanmoins toujours une autre
obsession dans ma vie c'est
l'apprentissage le partage de
connaissances et pour ça j'ai créé il ya
cinq ans une première start-up qui
voulaient faire des jeux des jeux qui
permettait d'apprendre et cette start-up
affaires dépôt de bilan ça arrive dans
la vie mais le hasard a voulu que à peu
près en même temps de ce dépôt de bilan
je rencontre un homme extraordinaire
idrissa berkane jeune de 27 ans
spécialiste en neurosciences qui était
exactement sur les mêmes idées que moi
la même éthique que moi faire des jeux
mais faire des jeux qui nous permettent
d'apprendre et avec lui on a donc créé
scandé ria pourquoi scandé ria parce
qu'on est tous les deux fans de la ville
d'alexandrie fsa alexandrie c'est le far
la grande bibliothèque et alexandrie en
arabe saïss comme des rias donc ce camp
derrière le nom était toujours trouvé je
vous dis ça parce qu'habituellement les
gens pensent que c'est volvo et la suède
ou autre chose que saab est dans c'est
pas du tout ça est alors savez pourquoi
la renaissance numérique
moi j'avais coutume de parler des
rupture que nous vivons puissiez parler
de rupture ben oui c'est bien mais enfin
c'est pas très porteur d'espoir et bien
jour je me suis aperçu que ce qu'on
vivait actuellement avait beaucoup de
points communs que la renaissance qu'est
ce qui se passe à la renaissance la
science la technologie font des progrès
extraordinaires
on invente le vilebrequin on invente la
cale sèche on avant que le parachute on
invente la perspective en peinture
énorme et surtout on commence à
disséquer les cadavres et on jette les
bases de la médecine moderne
andré vésale mais la renaissance c'est
aussi ce moment où l'ordre ancien
empêche de muter l'église catholique ne
veux pas que les gens s'enrichissent
intellectuellement et c'est ce que nous
vivons aujourd'hui
en ce moment la science la technologie
font des progrès fabuleux nous sommes
quand même la première génération avoir
vu des exoplanètes francs des contres
terme de regard sur le monde
on sait maintenant qu'il ya des planètes
qui tournent autour d'autres étoiles que
notre soleil
nous avons construit des ordinateurs
quantiques et surtout l'analogue de
l'ouverture du corps c'est le cerveau
nous faisons actuellement des progrès
extraordinaires en termes de
compréhension de ce qui se passe dans le
cerveau et tout un tas d'éléments qui
étaient considérées comme des maladies
psychologiques un l'autisme par exemple
bien aujourd'hui on commence à
comprendre d'où ça vient et on commence
à faire les choses et pourtant en ce
moment l'ordre ancien freine des quatre
fers
tous les jours vous le voyez ce combat
qui est très fractales ise entre des
gens qui pour moi c'est là où la
fracture numérique entre des gens qui
ont compris que le monde a été en train
de muter et des gens qui restent
toujours selon les méthodes et les
valeurs anciennes et entre autres pour
comprendre ça il faut comprendre bien
sûr qu'internet c'est un nouvel alphabet
mais surtout il faut comprendre il faut
adopter une posture systémique heart on
le dit c'est quoi la systémique comme ne
faut pas le refaire le coup des blagues
de fois je vous montre ce dessin il est
dramatique n'est ce pas le nombre de
fois moi surtout parisien je suis désolé
de pâtes bordelais mais où je suis dans
la file de droite parce que je fais
partie des gens pressés voilà donc une
fois qu'on a compris ça on a compris que
le monde était aujourd'hui il fallait
adopter les yeux d'un systémicien il
fallait regarder l'ensemble globalité du
système pour le comprendre et entre
autres c'est souvent on vous dit avant
c'était pas pareil
en fait quand vous regardez le champ de
la science la technologie wi la science
la technologie construisez corpus de
connaissances qui s'appuient les uns sur
les autres
mais dès que vous regardez le champ de
la sociologie des sentiments humains
finalement on n'invente rien c'est
finalement au circulo réexplorent des
formes du passé mon invente rien dire
heureusement parce que si on construit
des corpus de connaissances comme vous
savez au moyen-âge il était évident pour
tout le monde que tomber amoureux
c'était être malade
c'est pour ça qu'on invente et l'amour
courtois d'ailleurs pour restaurer
redonner un peu de crédit au sentiment
amoureux
mais finalement si les sentiments c'est
comme la science et la technologie
depuis le moyen-age on ne commettrai
plus cette erreur grave de tomber
amoureux ce serait un petit peu dommage
comme
bref mais en revanche nous avons vécu
nous bipèdes une véritable rupture et
cette rupture est la suivante quand moi
je suis né il y avait 2 3 milliards
d'individus sur terre aujourd'hui dans
la set comme le coupable je vous rassure
mais c'est quand même un peu
stakhanoviste mais sept milliards
d'individus dans un même vaisseau
spatial ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que nos journées sont
bourrés d'interaction voilà c'est ce que
nous vivons actuellement nous et à plus
de gens dans les rues plus de gens dans
le métro plus de gens dans les trains
dans les avions plus de collaborateurs
plus de clients plus de plus de plus de
et donc ça ça veut dire que nous sommes
dans un monde qui est sous pression et
un monde sous pression mais ça se gère
différemment il n'y a pas que les
voitures il ya l'information parce que
nous sommes dans un monde bourré
d'interaction nous sommes remplis
l'information et ça c'est ce qu'on vit
tous les jours
oh là là j'ai trop d'e-mails j'ai trop
de ceci j'ai trop seul je suis perdu
dans un océan d'informations et alors
que ce que l inverse tout le monde rêve
bien évidemment c'est d'arriver à sa
place est magnifique il ya twitter les
réseaux sociaux c'est beau le monde il
est tranquille et serbes
alors pourquoi ou plutôt comment faire
pour arriver à ça eh bien il faut
changer de posture est entre autres s'il
faut arrêter ce qu'on appelle les
modèles linéaires il faut atteindre ce
qu'on appelle l'homéostasie c'est
l'homéostasie c'est extraordinaire c'est
cette idée qu'un organisme est en
équilibre dynamique avec son
environnement
donc ne rêvez pas comment le monde ou
comme on saura dans dix ans quand les
conditions de température et de pression
auront totalement changé dans trois mois
en revanche il faut maintenir cet
équilibre et le corps humain est un
magnifique exemple domeo stasi qui fasse
moins 10 ou plus 30 dehors la
température interne de votre corps est
constante et pourquoi votre corps humain
interne homéostasie parce qu'ils
s'échangent de l'information
tous les éléments de votre coeur de
votre corps votre coeur vous graver vos
poumons passent leur temps à s'échanger
d'information et c'est ce qui assure cet
équilibre d'ailleurs quand la fondation
circulent moins bien ça s'appelle le
cancer et aux sait ce que ça veut dire
donc aujourd'hui tous les modèles qui
font mal circuler l'information qui font
mal circulé la connaissance sont des
modèles qui sont à proscrire parce qu'il
devienne totalement inefficace parce
qu'ils ne savent plus gérer la
complexité du monde donc les hiérarchies
bien sûr les modèle en silo et les
modèle basé sur la méfiance
c'est extraordinaire ce que la méfiance
empêche l'information et le savoir de
circuler et donc à l'inversé il faut
construire des choses qui sont vraiment
basé sur autre chose que sur la méfiance
et cela il faut construire un monde
totalement différemment alors la
connaissance c'est fabuleux un la
connaissance et là je vais reprendre il
manificat le robot einstein et là je
vais reprendre les propos de mon habit
idriss mon confondateur la connaissance
est infinie lui il ajoute parce qu'il
est plus jeune que moi la connerie aussi
cet infini ça va de pair quoi bon moi je
voudrais pas mais c est surtout la coop
d'alsace avec la connaissance double
tous les neuf ans et quand vous regardez
les universités chinoises c'est tous les
cinq ans que les universités chinoises
ont produit deux fois plus de papier que
le cinq ans auparavant et la
connaissance elle est collégiale
regarder wikipedia magnifique exemple
d'intelligence collective
wikipedia donc on arrive à créer de la
connaissance en commun d'ailleurs il y a
deux équations dont vous voyez le
mathématicien en mois ressort de temps
en temps la première équation c'est que
quand on se met ensemble quand on crée
quelque chose ensemble et bien la
connaissance congénères est supérieure à
la somme des connaissances de chacune
des deux parties les connaît la
connaissance finalement le fond plus que
s'équilibrer as tu connait quelque chose
je connais quelque chose et d'un seul
coup on découvre une troisième chose et
puis surtout cette équation que j'adore
la connaissance et la tension que
multiplie le temps donc si vous voulez
vraiment acquérir la connaissance il
faut y mettre de la tension et vous
savez la base de la tension je vais dire
un mot quand même assez surprenant c'est
l'amour plus vous aimez quelque chose
plus vous y allez y apporter la tension
et plus vous y allez finalement acquérir
des connaissances et donc cette idée que
l'apprentissage peut passer par là doit
passer par la tension et doit passer par
l'amour c'est quand même quelque chose
assez fantastique
or il y a quelque chose qui permet
vraiment de réaliser cet élément-là ce
quelque chose vous allez le voir je vais
vous proposer quatre manière d'acquérir
la connaissance et vous allez voir
laquelle va vraiment vous parler numéro
un c'est dramatique
anaqua barça moi je suis déprimé moi je
rêvais l'on s'endort et tout le mec il
est loin il ya des transparents presse
comme les miens et puis etc
savais que ça c'est dramatique parce que
les neurosciences vous dise une chose
quand vous êtes comme ça dans un amphi
magistral qu'est ce que vous faites
votre cerveau est mobilisé sur une tâche
qui consiste à décoder une onde sonore
et la transformer en de l'écrit et votre
cerveau il est il ne fait que ça il fait
rien d'autre
donc on me fait rien d'autre mais qu'est
ce que vous faites en rentrant chez vous
vous relisez vos notes
pas terrible comme comme méthode
d'apprentissage quoi bon celle là bas
mon dieu pauvre gamin sans c1 soit le
gamin c'est pas un einstein et il va
souffrir
soit c'est un einstein ses profs qui va
souffrir face aux dans les deux cas il
va y avoir de la souffrance bon c'est
que les neuro alors là tous les deux
roues scientifique vous diront que cette
idée qu'il faut souffrir pour apprendre
ça vient peut-être de sparte mais tout
juste quoi ah là ça devient intéressant
savait que l'être humain nous les
humains nous sommes le seul mammifère à
ne pas apprendre en jouant ou plutôt
nous faisons jusqu'à l'âge de 3-4 ans et
après nous avons oublié ça mais c'est
les autres mammifères n'oublie pas ils
apprennent en juin et puis ça bah voilà
ça c'est magnifique
il ya une équipe on a un objectif on
joue et on joue et on apprend énormément
on apprend bien évidemment à condition
qu'ils aient le sentiment de l'équipe et
que on apprenne ensemble donc si vous
voulez le jeu et c'est cette obsession
que j'ai depuis longtemps le jeu comme
base de l'apprentissage
alors quand je dis je je dis surtout pas
des serious games surtout pas les jeux
sérieux ça c'est mettre du sien sur du
chien en quoi ça fait plaisir à des drh
mais non vous savez allez bon on va
jouer l'entreprise et puis alors je te
mets un badge et puis tu as un badge si
tu arrives au niveau non ça d'ailleurs
il ya un an nous avons une très grande
neuroscientifique française daphné
bavelier qui disent ah oui ça peu de
choses près comme bêtes du chocolat sur
du brocoli à vous par là alors là il ya
votre cerveau paf bah oui parce que le
chocolat c'est très nutritifs mais le
brocoli ou si ses traits du tri tiff
meiway que la somme des de nutrition
s'adonnent pas quelque chose de terrible
1 s'est passé ça a pourtant vous allez
dans vos cours puis vous avez un cours
nourrissant puis un autre court
nourrissant puis finalement à la fin
vous avez une indigestion
non non c'est des vrais jeux et riche
marx
un homme très intéressant et riche marx
était un colonel allemand qui général
allemand qui dirigeait tout le front
atlantique et un jour le 6 juin 1944 et
riche marque décide de jouer un cric
spiel et il décide de jouer les alliés
histoire vraie le soir il envoie un
e-mail à hitler ou l'équivalent de
l'e-mail de l'époque en lui disant ça
lui fait en disant ça c'est véridique
j'ai tout compris ils vont débarquer en
normandie ils vont débarquer à marée
basse et ils vont débarquer en pleine
lune rien qu'en jouant les alliés à et
riche marx avait fait tout le plan de
débarquement et la chance qu'on a eues
ces kits l'air étaient environnés
d'énarques bon teint ou équivalent
qu'ils ont dit non non non non non non
c'est un petit joueur non c'est nous les
stratèges jamais les alliés ne
commettront des telles stupidités donc
voyons en jouant on peut bien finalement
trouvé des choses à son fabuleuse world
of warcraft alors moi qui enseigne dans
une école
je suis ravie quand je rencontre un
hardcore gamer
ça fait des chefs de projets
extraordinaires pourquoi parce que quand
vous êtes dans votre voix grave que vous
commettez une erreur et que toute votre
équipe et zigouiller bas il ya de bonnes
nouvelles si vous êtes quand même
physiquement intacts
une nouvelle c'est que les autres qui
vous tombent dessus et vous engueule
donc quelque part on se bouge quoi est
ce que vous savez que l'humanité a joué
sept millions d'années à world of
warcraft la somme cumulée de tous les
joueurs c'est 7 millions d'années vous
rendez compte la puissance qu'il ya
derrière ça mais est ce que vous savez
aussi que l'armée américaine a mis au
point un jeu pour recruter ses bidasses
et qu' il y a trois mois l'armée
américaine a recruté même le concepteur
de call of duty fsa ces jeux-là pan pan
pan pan pan pan
il faut faire ce personnes shooting
d'ailleurs je rassure toutes les
personnes dans la salle qui ont des
gamins qui passent trop de temps sur ces
jeux là ça développe la concentration
donc ça a été montrée donc à condition
de bord d un peu quand même la chose
d'expliquer que ce avant la
concentration simcity le moins de gamin
de 13 ans qui jouait mme stinne city
sait très bien que si on augmente trop
les impôts les gens consomment moins
qu'une fille née il ya moins d'impôts
on aurait il y un gamin de 3 ans etc
mais ce qui est intéressant c'est que
les libéraux libéraux au sens anglo
saxons c'est à dire ceux qui font
confiance à leur équipe réussissent
mieux que ceux qui sont dans un mode
dirigiste ça c'est extraordinaire
une belle preuve quoi et puis ouais ça
c'est pas terrible ça s'appelle une
coelioscopie d'instruments mais je vous
conseille si un jour vous avez ce genre
de problème de demander un chirurgien
qui jouent aux jeux vidéo parce qu'il ya
plusieurs études universitaires qui ont
montré que les chirurgiens qui jouent
aux jeux vidéo sont des biens meilleurs
chirurgiens que les autres sur tout ce
qui concerne la coelioscopie
donc vous allez de géorgie un docteur ce
que vous jouez au jeu vidéo n'ont pas
écouté je suis désolé je veux pas de
vous j'en veux un autre quoi et puis ben
voila et puis nous on a développé même
des jeux ou au fait de la stratégie sur
une carte et je peux vous assurer que
pas plus tard que la semaine dernière
c'est extraordinaire de voir justement
20,6 you de d'opérateurs de télécoms de
pays d'afrique et du moyen orient qui
étaient comme des gamins à celui qui
aurait la stratégie la plus belle elle
est la meilleure et c'est passionnant de
les voir absolument engager comme ça je
terminerais presque sur des plus belles
histoires de ce monde numérique que nous
connaissons le sida du macaque et le
macaque à un sida il est très important
de comprendre comment ce sida fonctionne
pour comprendre le sida de l'être humain
et il se trouve que il y à une enzyme
qui est très importante
et comme souvent en biologie les
scientifiques avaient la formule à deux
dimensions de l'enzyme
mais la formule à deux dimensions ne
sert à rien parce que pour traiter la
maladie ce qu'il faut c'est la formule à
trois dimensions est passé d'une formule
à plat une formule à trois dimensions
c'est très très compliqué et pendant 15
ans les plus grands biologistes du monde
entier se sont cassé les dents sur la
découverte de cette enzyme pendant 15
ans jusqu'en 2011 ou d'un seul coup
l'université de washington à seattle à
une idée et si on en faisait un jeu pas
un jeu pour les scientifiques
un jeu pour des joueurs et donc les
joueurs avaient une interface où il
fallait replier des molécules c'était
des équipes de 20 joueurs et il y avait
une fonction énergétique qui était
calculée par les scientifiques est bien
évidemment le but
jeu c'était d'avoir la fonction
énergétique la plus élevée qui donnait
la formule de l'enzyme s'appelle fold it
pour repliement la formule était troué
en dix jours dix jours de joueurs en
réseau dont des gamins de 13 ans des
garagistes esterra ont aidé les
scientifiques qui séchait depuis 15 ans
devant la rupture et représentations en
3d cette molécule est d'ailleurs les
scientifiques sont allé un cran plus
loin puisque maintenant il développe des
enzymes de synthèse qu'il donne aux
joueurs et les joueurs améliorent
l'enzyme de synthèse
donc voilà ce qui est intéressant c'est
que quand j'analyse les élèves face à
leurs enseignants mais aussi les
citoyens face aux politiques ou les
clients face aux entreprises où les
salariés face aux managers
je retrouve toujours cette même
constante du fun de l'engagement et du
partage
les jeunes dans les entreprises non mais
attendez attendez nous ce qu'on veut
c'est des challenge donc film new day
challenge
et puis on y arrivera pareil les
citoyens non nous on veut participer à
l'élaboration de la ville on veut on
veut bien ce qui est intéressant c'est
que le jeu ça permet ça puisque le jeu
bah c'est fun s'y engageant etc
collégiale et donc j'ai envie de vous
dire jouer jouer parce que le jeu c'est
la fibre optique de l'apprentissage
merci